el 18 de octubre un día de posibles
huelgas en toda Francia cuatro
sindicatos convocan a una jornada de
cese de actividades en cuatro sectores
en la sncf la empresa Nacional de
ferrocarriles de Francia la cgt y el sud
los dos sindicatos mayoritarios
necesitan a los empleados a dejar de
trabajar y se esperan interrupciones en
la red los trabajadores del transporte
público también se movilizarán el martes
incluidos los del metro de París y ya
están en marcha las huelgas en las
centrales nucleares del norte de Francia
los trabajadores iniciaron la protesta
el jueves exigiendo mejores salarios
cada día se suman al movimiento otro
centros
y esperamos realmente resolverlo
rápidamente para evitar ciertos apagones
durante el invierno
una movilización que también se ha
extendido a Los camioneros a instancias
de la cgt cuatro sindicatos se unen de
Cara a la acción del martes otros sin
embargo se desmarcan de los faros Sepa
la comida no es la convergencia de las
luchas lo que aumentará los salarios
Lamento decirlo una importante
demostración de fuerza para la cgt que
lleva varios años perdiendo afiliados el
sindicato cuenta con este movimiento
para recuperar el rumbo lo que se hace
aún más importante por el hecho de que
todavía no se ha elegido al sucesor de
philippe Martínez al frente de la
asociación el próximo año